In this problem, a vertical furnace is
used to recycle aluminum scrap. Exhaust
gas from the furnace contains trace
aluminum vapor. The aluminum
concentration in the exhaust stream is
120 parts [clears throat] per million
and the total exhaust gas flow rate is
150,000 cubic feet per hour measured at
70° F and 1 atm.
What is the aluminum emission rate in
pounds? Assume ideal gas behavior.
So in this problem, we're given a flow
rate in cubic feet per hour
at a specified temperature and pressure.
Before doing anything else, let's check
whether the ideal gas law can help us
convert that volume into something
mass-based.
So, if you search for ideal gas in the
reference manual, you'll eventually find
on page 106 that for one pound mole of
an ideal gas at 70° F and 1 atmosphere,
the molar volume is 387
feet per pound mole. If that value is
provided, you can use it directly and
move on. But to make this problem more
useful, let's assume that it wasn't
given. Searching again for ideal gas
brings you to the section on ideal gas
mixtures on page 52. The page
immediately after provides an equation
for adjusting gas concentrations between
temperatures referenced to 273.15
Kelvin.
To use that equation, we first need to
convert our temperature from Fahrenheit
to Kelvin. Searching temperature
conversion takes us to page 213 where
that relationship is also given.
So first we'll convert to Celsius. So we
will say 70° Fus 32
over 1.8
will give us just about 21.1°
C.
And then plugging that
into the conversion to Kelvin
gives us 294.26°
Kelvin. And just below that on the next
page, the reference manual gives us the
fundamental ideal gas constant.
This is 359 cubic feet per mole at 273°
Kelvin and one atmosphere.
Note that I think it should say cubic
feet per pound mole just like the 287
number before.
So now we can adjust for our
temperature.
Adjusting for that temperature brings us
back to the same 387
foot cubed per pound mole that was
listed on page 106 in the manual.
So that's reassuring and it's useful to
know in case the exam gives you a
different temperature than the one in
this problem. Now let's step back and
look at units. We are given a flow rate
in feet cubed per hour, an aluminum
concentration in parts per million, and
a molar volume in feet cubed per pound
mole.
Since our final answer needs to be in
pounds per hour, the molar volume
clearly belongs in the denominator,
converting the cubic feet into pound
moles of gas.
And because parts per million is a mole
fraction, multiplying by 1 million
converts it into the fraction of
aluminum in the gas stream. So the only
remaining unit that we need now is mass
per mole.
If we search molecular weight in the
reference manual,
this will take us to page 193 where
aluminum has a molecular weight of 27.
The units here are mass per mole, which
in English means pound per pound mole.
Now, that's exactly what we need to
cancel the mole units and end up with
pounds per hour.
So, let's write this out so that we can
see it.
We have our flow rate of 150,000 cubic
feet per hour
times 120 parts per million.
So, the 120 will be on the top.
time 27
pound per pound mole
over
the 1 million that goes with the 120
times
feet cubed
per mole. And as we can see
our feet cube cross out.
We're looking for pounds per hour over
here. Hour remains
and pound mole and whoops pound mole
also cross out here. Simplifying this
down, we can see that the final aluminum
emission rate is about 1.25
pounds per hour, which is our second
answer in our list. So the math itself
in this problem is really
straightforward. And this problem is
basically just testing a lot of other
things. So what you have to first we
have to know what information exists in
the reference manual. We searched page
106 to find the original molar volume.
We also used page 53 as well as 214 and
the temperature conversions on 213 to
calculate this same number again if the
temperature was provided at a different
number.
And then we needed to find the molecular
weight in order to make sure that we
were able to convert all of our givens
into the final amount of aluminum
emissions at the correct rate. So if
you're like me and you're not an expert
in these types of problems, the most
valuable part of practicing problems
like this really isn't the arithmetic.
It's learning what tools are available
in the reference manual so that you can
find them more quickly the next time you
see a similar problem on exam day. Also,
if you have a faster way of solving this
or understand a concept that I missed
here, please feel free to correct me in
the comments. And that's it.